supongamos que tengo una matriz a que es
una matriz de n porque tiene n renglones
y k columnas así que a se ve así vamos a
decir que sus columnas son a1 a2 hasta
hasta
que esas son las columnas de a muy bien
vamos a suponer además que estos las
columnas de a son vectores linealmente
independientes a 1
a 2
hasta
hasta acá son vectores linealmente
independientes recuerden l y significa
linealmente independientes y qué
significa eso pues significa que si yo
escribo una combinación lineal x 1 a 1 +
x2 x a 2
más si hasta xk por acá donde cada equis
y es un escalar y digo que esto tiene
que ser igual al vector cero el único
modo de que esto pase es si sólo si cada
xy es igual a cero al escalar cero otro
modo de decir lo mismo es decir que el
producto de la matriz a por el vector
cuyas entradas son x1 y x2 hasta xk este
producto es igual a cero si y sólo si
si y sólo si o más bien que la única
solución a esto la única solución única
solución
que el vector x que es este vector de
aquí sea igual al vector 0 bien y de
otro modo aún decir esto o para ir
resumiendo todo esto es que las columnas
y las columnas las columnas son
linealmente independientes esto me
implica que el espacio nulo o la nulidad
de esta matriz
es igual al conjunto que sólo contiene
al vector 0 esto esto de aquí es
exactamente lo mismo que decir que la
única solución a esta ecuación de aquí
es el vector 0 ahora bien a es una
matriz de n por acá y no sé bien cuáles
sean sus dimensiones así que en
particular no sé si a es una matriz
cuadrada por lo tanto no puedo decir
nada acerca de si a es invertirle pero a
partir de a puedo construir una matriz
que veremos que si es invertible vamos a
considerar la matriz a transpuesta por a
y como a es una matriz de n por acá
entonces a traspuesta es una matriz de k
por n de modo que el producto de estas
dos matrices tendría dimensiones k
porque así que es una matriz cuadrada
esta de aquí es una matriz cuadrada a
transpuesta x a
y entonces yo sé yo sé que si tengo una
matriz cuadrada
cuadrada que además tiene
con columnas
linealmente independientes columnas
linealmente independientes entonces
entonces
qué sucede pues si yo la llevo a su
forma escalonada reducida por renglones
la forma escalonada reducida por
renglones de a
va a tener
no tiene cada columnas pivote cada
columnas
pivote
así que esto esto sucede la forma
escalona reducida de a tiene columnas
pivote y por lo tanto esta debe ser la
matriz identidad de acá por acá y esto
esto ya me dice
esto de aquí
ya me dice que
por lo tanto
es invertible
así que lo que me estoy preguntando es
si esta matriz de aquí
es invertible
que en realidad esto es una pregunta es
invertible la matriz a transpuesta por
up y bueno aquí quizás no debí de haber
usado así no otra letra porque lo voy a
checar para transpuesta por a ok así que
lo que voy a checar es que las columnas
de transpuesta por a que es una matriz
cuadrada son linealmente independientes
y entonces todo esto me dirá que la
matriz a transpuesta x a es invertible
así que como le voy a hacer pues voy a
empezar considerando un vector b que va
a pertenecer al espacio nulo de a
transpuesta por a entonces esto qué
quiere decir pues quiere decir que a
traspuesta por a por el vector b es
igual al vector 0 esa es la definición
de que un vector esté en el espacio nulo
de una matriz pero ahora bien yo puedo
multiplicar toda esta ecuación de ambos
lados por el vector b transpuesta
a la derecha perdón por la izquierda
así que sería de transpuesta x a
transpuesta por a por el vector b es
igual a de transpuesta por el vector 0
ahora bien yo sé
yo sé que cuando tengo el producto de
dos matrices más vamos a hacerlo
directamente con el vector yo sé que
detrás pues está por a transpuesta si lo
considera como el producto matrices ya
vimos que esto es lo mismo que
por d
ver todo eso transpuesto así que
yo voy a sustituir esto de aquí por a
por the transpuesta y escribir esto como
por haber transpuesto por a
por d
es igual a de transpuesta por 0
recuerden esto identificando matrices
perdón a está identificando vectores con
matrices de acá por 1
ok entonces también nosotros sabemos de
algún vídeo anterior que si tengo un
vector
y consideraron consideró ya transpuesta
porque esto es lo mismo que el producto
punto o producto interior consigo mismo
ok siempre que tengo un vector y lo
transponga y lo multiplicó por otro
vector es lo mismo que tomar el producto
punto de los dos vectores así que bueno
esto me diría esta cosa de aquí me dice
que me transpuesta por el vector 0 es
igual a esto es lo mismo que de producto
punto con el vector 0 pero ve el
producto punto con el vector 0 es
sencillamente cero
así que por un lado tengo eso y acá que
tengo esto de a por detrás a por be
transpuesto por ave es igual a cero
así que si vuelvo a aplicar esta
identidad de aquí obtendría que a por be
producto interior producto punto consigo
mismo contra por b es igual a cero pero
ahora fíjense quién es esto de aquí
quién es esto pues esto es la norma de a
por b
al cuadrado y eso es igual a cero así
que cuál es el único vector que tiene
normas cero pues es precisamente el
vector cero
esto me implica que a x b
es igual al vector 0 bueno pero ahora
qué pasa entonces esta ecuación de aquí
me diría
esto de aquí me dice que ve pertenece al
espacio nulo de la matriz
ok pero entonces vamos a juntar todo lo
que tenemos teníamos que d estaba en el
espacio nulo a ver déjenme lo escribo
así que estaba en el espacio nulo d
transpuesta por a y a partir de eso
concluimos que b tenía que estar en el
espacio nulo de a así que este conjunto
de aquí está contenido en está contenido
en el espacio nulo de la matriz a pero
éste simplemente consistía en el
conjunto que sólo tiene al vector cero
esa era una de las consecuencias de que
las columnas de fueran linealmente
independientes
así que qué sucede pues entonces
entonces de
tiene que ser igual al vector 0 y otra
forma de decir esto es
la única solución
por lo tanto estos tres puntitos
significan por lo tanto la única
solución única solución
solución a la ecuación a transpuesta x a
por un vector x es igual al vector 0
x igual al vector 0
pero eso que me dice pues es el mismo
argumento que hicimos acá arriba solo
que al revés eso me diría
entonces
a las columnas las columnas
de a transpuesta por a
son
son linealmente realmente
independientes
perfecto ahora bien que me dice eso pues
qué es lo que tenía ahora tengo una
matriz cuadrada a transpuesta x cuyas
columnas son linealmente independientes
así que entonces por estar acá la forma
escalonada reducida por renglones de la
matriz
a transpuesta por a
es sencillamente la identidad de cada
porque pero eso que me dice pues me dice
que
me lo pongo con otro color me dice que a
transpuesta por a es invertible
es invertible
así que tenemos este resultado bastante
bonito porque partimos de una matriz
cuyas columnas eran linealmente
independientes pero cuyas dimensiones
quizás no la no le permitían a esa
matriz ser invertible porque quizás no
era una matriz cuadrada y a partir de
ella construimos esta matriz a
traspuesta por a que ahora sí podemos
decir no preguntarnos si es invertible
sino afirmarlo
es invertible
así que que las columnas de una matriz
sean igualmente independientes me
permite construir la matriz a
transpuesta por a que a fuerzas tendrá
que ser una matriz invertible